hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
book five of dostoyevsky's the brothers
karamazov contains one of the most
famous passages from the work it's
chapter 5 entitled
the grand inquisitor in which the grand
inquisitor
you could say questions really he more
talks to
the recently appeared
quite possibly jesus christ on
earth and ivan brings this
up as a response
to alyosha who is in his
turn responding to ivan setting out
essentially an argument about the
problem of evil
and alyosha says
[Music]
that you ask just now if there's in the
whole world a being who could and would
have the right to forgive
there is such a being and he can forgive
everything forgive all
and for all because he himself gave his
innocent blood for all
and for everything you've forgotten
about him but it's on him
that the structure is being built and
it's to him they will cry out just art
thou
lord for thy waves have been revealed
and ivan says i was just waiting for you
to bring this guy
up he says i haven't forgotten about him
on the contrary i was wondering why you
hadn't brought him up for so long
because in discussions
your people meaning religious people
usually
trot him out first thing and then he
says
alyosha i composed a poem once about a
year ago
and i'll tell it to you and he's you
know what what a
he means by a poem here is some sort of
literary creation
that ivan came up with and essentially
has memorized
although in the way that he's going to
present it he
has some side comments and little extra
conversations
here and there so ivan is presenting
this
poem as a
response as a way of rebutting
this bringing up christ and it's kind of
a strange thing because it doesn't
actually provide us with some sort of
knock down
now i gotcha sort of argument instead it
presents this this vignette
between the grand inquisitor who
represents a certain kind of person
and christ or somebody who might be
christ
you know we think that he is in the poem
although
ivan calls us into question at one point
so in the the poem he says that
1500 years have passed since
the time of christ appearing and having
his disciples his crucifixion
all the other things that have gone
along with that and
in this entire time people have been
waiting
for him to come back and ivan talks
about higher powers
coming down to earth he says it back
then it was
customary in poetic works to bring
higher powers down to earth and he goes
through a lot of
discussions about that and
there's a little bit of a digression
here
but then what we find is that
he says 15 centuries have gone by since
men ceased to receive
pledges from heaven believe what the
heart tells you for heaven offers no
pledge only faith in what the heart
tells you
then he says true there were also many
miracles
there were saints who performed
miraculous healings
to some righteous people the queen of
heaven came down
but the devil never rests and there had
already arisen in mankind some doubt
as to the authenticity of these miracles
so you know miracles are one of those
sorts of things that
by their very nature are going to be
you know rather unusual they violate the
laws of nature however we want to think
about it
and some people are going to believe in
them and some people aren't
he says then that a heresy arose
and the heretics began denying miracles
and then those who believe
became all the more ardent in their
belief
and what are they doing the people are
crying out to god
asking god to return to them begging for
mercy
wanting to have that presence
that is you know recorded in in the
gospels and all these other
texts that people are talking about this
so
he says after so many centuries they
began pleading with faith and fire god
our lord reveal thyself
to us and so
christ comes again ivan says he desired
to appear to people if only for a moment
to his tormented
suffering people rank with sin but
loving him like
children so christ comes out of mercy
and in the story he comes in the time of
the inquisition
in spain he comes down he says to the
scorch
squares of a southern town were just the
day before in a splendid auto defeat
which is fire burning up heretics
or other people in the presence of the
king the cardinal grand inquisitor
burned
almost 100 heretics at once odd myorum
glorium day which is to the greater
glory of god
so christ appears quietly
inconspicuously but strange to say
everyone recognized him
and then ivan has a little aside here
this could be one of the best passages
of the poem
i mean why it is they exactly they
recognize him
people are drawn to him by an invincible
force they flock to him surround him
follow them the son of love shines in
his heart rays of light enlightenment
and power
stream from his eyes and pouring over
the people shake their hearts with
responding love
he stretches forth his hands to them
blesses them and from the touch of him
even if only in his garments comes a
healing power and he gives you some
examples of this
an old man who's blind and then finally
there's a a daughter a young woman who's
died
and her mother says
if it's really you jesus raise my child
and then you know we have a sort of
repetition of one of the
narratives from the new testament
christ comes and looks with compassion
says talithikumi and the damsel arose
the girl
rises up in her coffin sits up and
smiling looks around in wide-eyed
astonishment
there's a commotion among the people
cries weeping and at this very moment
the grand
inquisitor arrives now the grand
inquisitor you would think
since you know he's a christian and he's
been burning all the heretics who denied
miracles
you'd think that this guy would be like
whoa this is amazing
you know jesus is returned i've been
hoping for this my entire life
that's not what actually happens instead
it's almost the reverse
he tells his guards arrest that guy
and they the crowd parts they arrest him
they take him to a prison cell and
later on that night the grand inquisitor
goes down there
to question him now he's not actually
going to
question him in any real way i suppose
you could say he's posing
questions to him but he's not getting
any answers because
the person who's just been doing these
miracles doesn't say anything to him
except at the very end where he gives
them a kiss
so what's the rest of
this poem it's the grand inquisitor
making some arguments giving some
explanations
issuing some challenges to
this christ who has appeared before
his people and
it's interesting because again another
little digression
in the story where alyosha breaks in and
says is this boundless fantasy or some
mistake on the old man's part some
impossible
qui pro quo now we're used to hearing
quid pro quo which means one thing for
another
cui pro quo means taking one person
for another so like maybe it was a
vagrant who happened to have
drawn a crowd and the old man uh his
eyes don't work that well and he's like
well that guy is pretending to be christ
or
maybe is christ we're going to take him
in
and and ivan says it doesn't really
matter
that much as far as the story goes
it says assume it's the latter if you
like if you want it to be qui pro quo
let it be
of course the man is 90 years old might
have lost his mind over his idea
he might have been struck by the
prisoner's appearance could be simple
delirium could be all these sorts of
things
the only thing is that the old man needs
to speak
out that finally after all his 90 years
he speaks out and says aloud all that he
has been silent about
for 90 years so this is the old man
making his
own position clear making the reasons
why he has been doing the things that
he's doing and why other people like him
are as well he's essentially giving a
speech
to christ to god incarnate
about why his services are no longer
needed
and why him coming to his people is
actually
making some trouble so he says
this is going back a little bit is it
you
receiving no answer he quickly adds
don't answer be silent after all
what could you say i know too well what
you would say
you have no right to add anything to
what you've already said once
meaning you did your thing back in
biblical times
and you don't get to add anything new
here
we've got it from this point we meaning
the church
the religious authorities the
intelligentsia whoever
it's supposed to be he says you've come
to interfere with us and you know it
yourself
you know what's going to happen tomorrow
we're going to burn you we're going to
kill you
and that entire crowd is going to be
cool with that
they're going to they're gonna watch it
and they're gonna do
nothing to stop it from happening and
they'll actually be okay
with it so he goes on
and he says the old man points out to
him he has no right to add anything
to what has already been said once that
if you like is the most basic feature of
roman catholicism in my opinion at least
everything has been handed over by you
to the pope therefore everything now
belongs to the pope and you may as well
not
come at all now or at least don't
interfere with us for the time being
and so yeah this may be a little bit of
a misrepresentation you know
from the orthodox perspective of the the
catholics but there is something to this
the idea is that listen we don't need
you the founder
anymore even if you happen to be god we
are
taking care of things don't rock the
boat
don't interfere so that's an interesting
thing to say to
what's supposed to be the not just
originator but object of worship
of your your group another
key point that he's going to be making
that we'll explore
in more depth is that the church and the
grand inquisitor and his types
have succeeded in getting people to
freely
give up their freedom christ
came to bring freedom and gave it to
people
through his sacrifice and what do they
do with that freedom freedom is a hard
thing to to live with it's a hard thing
to manage this
is a you know central existentialist
theme
that many people can't handle freedom
they choose to give it up to somebody to
something
else in this case it's to the church
another key thing that he brings up and
this occupies a lot
a large part of the poem is the three
temptations
and you know if you want to find these
temptations they're in the gospels
christ early on in his ministry
or you might even say before his
ministry goes out into the desert to
fast for 40 days
and nights and the devil comes to him
and issues these three temptations the
first one is
you're pretty hungry aren't you guy why
don't you turn those stones into bread
you could do it in just you know saying
a word and then he could
you know not be hungry and in this case
the the temptation
is not going to be for christ himself
it's
instead going to be for the people are
they going to
prioritize bread over other things and
there's
you know several other temptations as
well
but he goes on and he says that um
here's here's the the passage the dread
and intelligence spirit the spirit of
self-destruction and non-being the great
spirit spoke with you in the wilderness
and has been passed on to us in books
that he supposedly tempted you did he
really
was it possible to say anything more
than what he proclaimed his three
questions
and at the same time if ever a real
thundering miracle was performed on
earth it was on that day
the miracle lay precisely in the
appearance of these three questions
if it was possible to imagine just as a
trial and example that these three
questions of the dread spirit had been
lost from the books without a trace
and it was necessary they'd be restored
thought up and invented a new
to that end all the wise men on earth
rulers high priest scholars philosophers
poets were brought together
given this task to think up to invent
three questions such as would
not only correspond to the scale of the
event but would express in three words
the entire future history of mankind do
you think all the combined wisdom of
earth could think of anything
faintly resembling these three questions
these three questions set out something
essential to the human condition and not
just for individuals
but for humans living together in
society
so that's going to be a very important
part of what the grand inquisitor is
explaining and then finally another
point that the grand inquisitor
is going to make is that he himself and
his brethren
are taking on this sacrifice themselves
of
managing humanity taking the freedom
that humanity has given them that
they've talked humanity into giving away
and giving humanity happiness instead in
place
of that freedom they're the people who
are managing it the elite
they are not happy they are actually
pretty busy
they have a lot of problems and they
know the truth
so they act in freedom to take away
others freedom
to make those others happy and
christ coming along would upset the
proverbial apple cart
you know so the grand inquisitor has to
get rid of him and that's
what the conversation
if you want to call it it's rather a
one-sided conversation a monologue
although it does have some
interrogatory points between
the grand inquisitor in christ is really
all about
and now come back out of this this is a
poem
that has characters in it
that ivan himself has come up with and
is positioning
them this way and then providing to his
brother eliot
dostoevsky is providing this to us
the readers
you